so over the past couple of weeks some of
you have directed me to this very
strange project it's a city that's 170
kilometers long
500 meters tall
and it's basically a line cutting
straight across the desert with a facade
made of mirrors
and you can travel from one end to the
other end in just 20 minutes it's got an
ultra super high speed public transit
which eliminates the need for cars and
prioritizes walking at first i thought
it was a metaverse project but it is a
real project the initial estimates for
this project was 500 billion dollars and
now they're estimating at one trillion
dollars
and it's expected to house nine million
residents there's been a lot of
marketing around this so let's unpack
this project a little bit from the
design and urban planning point of view
so a little bit of context neom is a
part of the saudi government's bigger
initiative to diversify the economy away
from oil and as a part of their plan
they're investing heavily into
infrastructure projects as well as
education tourism research anti-aging
technology and there's a really big
focus on future industries like
renewable power and the saudi arabian
government set up an entire zone for the
neon development in an area called
tabook there's areas that's already
finished construction including a
seaside resort a massive development for
the royal family and an airport directly
connecting to riyadh which is the
capital of saudi arabia
the line is probably the most public and
heavily marketed part of this neon
developments the graphics to date have
been really beautiful and really
compelling according to muhammad bin
salman this concept has a bunch of
advantages that's gonna make this the
city of the future by the way it's gonna
have zero carbon emissions and it's
gonna run on clean renewable energy the
city is gonna be structured on three
different levels at ground level you're
gonna have your pedestrian zone there's
going to be no roads and no cars and
there's going to be tons of parks and
trees to encourage walking the second
level functions as a service level with
shops and other commercial spaces and on
the third level you got your goods and
transportation with this ultra high
speed transit system this connects the
different city modules so that all of
your activities can be done by public
transport or by walking and all of your
daily needs can be met pretty much
within a five minute walking distance
this whole idea is built on the premise
that most big cities
are born out of the industrial
revolution and they were built for
machines and cars and industry rather
than for people the line would save
humanity from this commuting nightmare
but is a rigid line really going to meet
people's needs
and is this really the most conducive
shape for a city
there's just a lot of questions that
come up when i look at this the first
one was the design's impact on the
natural habitat i mean
if the focus really is on green
technology and it's designed for
sustainability why does it literally cut
through the surroundings you know it
looks like it's forcing its way into
this irregular terrain and it doesn't
even take advantage of the coast which
to me seems like the most natural thing
to do i studied fragmented landscapes
and wildlife corridors in architecture
school when i was doing my project in
the korean demilitarized zone and
there's thousands of instances
throughout the world where natural
habitats have been fragmented from roads
or buildings it stops animal migration
it kills off weaker animal species it
limits genetic diversity it creates
inbreeding which creates genetic
disorders this is really just to name a
few and one of the things that humans
can do to help these situations is to
create these wildlife corridors and
honestly i don't know if this was
overlooked because the project is in the
desert but even within a desert there's
thousands of animals and plant species
like lizards snakes turtles sand cats
hares like literally thousands and i
would assume especially as you get
closer to the water you would have more
animal species so creating this massive
170 kilometer wall
it sounds really problematic also this
giant mirror wall is gonna reflect the
light and it's gonna create these two
really really hot heat zones and it's
gonna fry everything around it not to
mention birds flying into it the second
thing is transportation how does this
extremely long line cut transit time
compared to a rectangle or a circle the
proposal relies on this super fast
transit system that's going to take you
from one end to the other in just 20
minutes that would mean that the train
runs at
525 kilometers per hour if you're not
accounting for all the stops the fastest
train in the world is the shanghai
maglev which runs at 460 kilometers per
hour there's also successful examples of
how transit has been incorporated into
the streetscape at the fraction of the
cost of these bullet trains i feel like
this design and this concept of the line
is creating unnecessary issues and
trying to solve that issue with
expensive technology and i think design
should provide the best organic solution
and we should use technology to improve
on that
also
organic cities
they grow you know how is this line
gonna allow for growth do you just keep
extending the line like adding more
modules or do you add perpendicularly in
which case it wouldn't be a line anymore
also if you look at studies on
innovation throughout history like where
good ideas come from by stephen johnson
he says that innovation
grew exactly when cities started to grow
and that's because there's a lot of
cross-pollination and accidental meeting
of ideas he describes the different
environmental examples that breed
innovation and every single instance
it's more of a maze than a
straightforward line so even if the
city's been programmed so that you can
access your grocery store or your local
coffee shop within a five-minute walking
distance if they're spending all of this
money on it i'm assuming that they're
gonna want innovators and leaders to
come live here but a linear rigid city
just doesn't really seem like the right
kind of environment for the breeding of
ideas there's also the pure logistics of
this as well for example let's say
you're making some mac and cheese but
you realize you don't have any butter
and how can you make any mac and cheese
without any butter and so you decide to
quickly go to the grocery store and if
you want to do it fast you have to walk
which with this type of verticality you
have to take the stairs if you want to
do it quick but if you have mobility
issues you're force to take the elevator
which we all know is a little bit slow
and as we've seen from the pandemic it's
the perfect breeding ground for disease
there's some talk of again another
high-tech vertical transportation system
which i'm sure will help revolutionize
transportation in a lot of already dense
cities but putting these constraints at
the outset of the design to serve this
very rigid concept i don't know how
sensible that is also
do you think we're going to be able to
cycle here we all know cycling to your
daily commute increases health lower
stress and obesity but you need roads of
some size which this design doesn't
really seem to allow for so
do you need to go to the basement floor
to ride your bike
i don't know i'm also not super sure how
much daylight you're gonna be able to
get in there this gray box is
residential but if you live all the way
over here that's a pretty unpleasant
situation for you and you're not going
to be able to get a lot of daylight so
maybe the ones on the lower level are
the servants and the workers and up here
that's where all the millionaires live
if this gets built i'm sure they're
going to figure out a way to properly
ventilate and structurally support this
but i think it's going to come at a
serious cost every structural engineer
is going to tell you that putting up a
massive slab wall
is going to create some serious lateral
stability issues so that means all of
this is going to need to have some beefy
structure this is the classic thermal
convection diagram the desert gets up to
55 degrees celsius that's 130 degrees
fahrenheit so if the roof of this thing
stays open
like in the renderings you're going to
need some serious cooling in there or
maybe they're just counting on all of
these areas being shaded most of the
time but then
i'm kind of curious
how do you get all of this lush greenery
right these are only the handful of the
many issues with this concept i feel
like a lot of unnecessary constraints
have been created to serve this very
simple concept it reminds me of like an
architecture student project that
inevitably gets ripped apart during a
crit but
let's say that they're able to resolve
the issue of daylight of walkability
they can make trees levitate and
sunlight can bend geometry but in the
end the question is still
who is gonna live here you know what
kind of communities are they gonna have
this is a one trillion dollar project
right
and they're estimating that it's going
to cost even more because all of these
technologies still have to be developed
and they're really trying to get the
state of art for everything the saudi
government is obviously not going to
foot the bill for everything you know
that's partially the whole point of this
entire marketing campaign it's to
attract investors in typical
developments of the size they're going
to phase it so that the profits from the
first phase can fund the second phase
and the second to the third and so on
and so forth but that would lead to
old and new sections and with typical
master plans these sections are designed
very strategically so that the first
phase you know even if it's a standalone
can be a livable and pleasant community
but with just a couple of strips of the
line which is the old section and which
is the new section and can it even
function as a strip on its own the idea
of a massive city is really cool but
who's going to want to move in there
when it's just one little section the
saudi government really wants to set up
neon as a free trade zone with its own
tax system and legal systems that's
separate from saudi arabia's super
conservative legal system and they're
really trying to create an environment
for global investors so maybe it'll be a
trade area where people come and go but
maybe few people will actually live
there they're also proposing that ai is
going to help us live more efficiently
reduce waste and live more comfortably
but
people are already skittish about giving
up their data even for the most
utilitarian needs and so to expect
people to do that for a city that's
built and funded by an authoritarian
government is i think asking for a lot
i have no doubt that this project is
going to push the boundaries of
technology they're already making some
really really interesting advancements
in desalination technology but building
a city from scratch instead of solving
the existing problems
is in my opinion the antithesis of
sustainability many parts of saudi
arabia don't even have a proper sewer
system the country's already full of
failed or abandoned projects and i think
they need to be spending this money on
improving the existing infrastructure
and improving the lives of the people
who already live there you know if
sustainability and creating a better
future really is their goal what's also
missing from their marketing campaigns
is that there's thousands of people
already living in this area there's a
tribal community that's been there for
centuries and neom is displacing
thousands of tribal members and i think
that brings us to the whole ethics
behind all this it is true that mohammed
bin salman is making a lot of social and
cultural progress in saudi arabia
especially for women since 2018 women
were allowed to drive
in 2019 they were allowed to apply for
passports meaning they could travel
without a male guardian and they're also
requiring equal pay for women for equal
work and you know before that women got
about half of what men were getting paid
for the same type of work and all of
these reforms are a huge step for
women's rights but the truth of the
matter is
nobody can criticize the prince or his
policies you guys might have heard of
the murder of jamal khashoggi who was a
saudi arabian journalist who was
critical of the prince and his policies
he was actually dismembered and murdered
in istanbul and cia reports found that
muhammad bin salman although he denies
it is the one who ordered the killing
he's also been responsible for some
serious human rights violations
including the arrest of a massive number
of political activists throughout the
country in this project as well there's
been zero consultation of people who are
gonna live there or who live there
already and so
i don't know maybe the purpose of this
whole project isn't to build a real city
after all maybe the whole purpose of
this project is to repair the reputation
and promote this positive image for the
prince and his kingdom and they're
saying to international investors look
women can drive now you can wear what
you want we're open for business i don't
want to get too bogged down into the
politics here but i think this is an
interesting point to end the video
architecture has been used throughout
history to promote a political agenda
and the simpler the idea the better
especially today with political
messaging being delivered right to our
fingertips as beautiful images and these
grand utopian visions
it's really hard to distinguish what's
what it really makes me wonder what is
our role in this i remember taking a
course on ethics in architecture and
this architect carl sapers he outlined
the ethical obligations of an architect
the architect has the obligation to
number one make sufficient income to
support the architect and his or her
family number two he has the
responsibility to the sometimes
conflicting requirements of serving the
client and number three to the sometimes
preceding and competing interest of
serving the public and number four he
has the responsibility to have devotion
to the art of architecture the second
and third are actually outlined in the
aia or aibc code of ethics and not all
of these points are equal if there's a
conflict between any of these points you
have to put the client's interests over
your own and you have to put the
public's interest over yours or the
clients what is the architect's
responsibility when they're asked to
come up with a concept like this anyways
i'll leave you guys with that i'm really
curious what you think so let me know
your thoughts in the comments if you
like this video i think you'll also like
the video where i talk about
architectural concepts in sci-fi movies
i'll leave it right here and with that
i'll see you guys in the next video
[Music]
you